here's another angle of this game that
that could get interesting if the rams
struggle offensively on sunday that
there has been an effort i think by the
rams to prop up this idea that todd
gurley has no problem whatsoever with cj
anderson carving into his workload and i
don't buy it and and i i looked at todd
gurley's quotes after the win over the
cowboys and they were so brief and they
were so concise you would think the rams
lost that game and and it just makes me
think that if they start giving too much
to cj anderson and if the rams do find
themselves in a tough game i said
earlier in the show on the radio side
fox should have a camera on todd gurley
because at some point you could see that
manifestation of frustration they're
trying so hard to make it look like
todd's a team guy no todd is an ultimate
competitor and this is the biggest game
he's ever played in his life more people
are watching this game than any game he
has ever played and he's going to want
to show up and be the guy and i think at
some level he does have a problem with
it he should have a problem with it i'd
have a problem with it why are you
giving more than half the carries to
this guy who was unemployed a month ago
they've done their best to contain it
but i feel like this is something we
need to keep an eye on because i think
it could blow if the rams can't run the
ball and if cj anderson keeps getting
attempts to not run the ball all right
so two things off of that one is i never
have a problem with guys being somewhat
selfish and saying i am the guy i am the
star i'm super talented and i want to
show it that to me is a great competitor
two todd gurley is a cat guy i think he
either owns a cat or said he wants to
own a cat you're not totally wrong
with the personality trait i like these
pads too okay
same way that's probably what you know
why it didn't work out for you so that's
clearly not some guy dog guys team guys
cat guys want the ball all the time
you're a cat guy well yeah i'm a big cat
yeah yeah i own a dog okay i own a dog
too okay i like your dog
your dog but i have cats too okay okay
you know people are gonna think they
stumbled across the wrong channel here
conversation but here's the other thing
i'll say to that too mike just to follow
up real quick first of all todd gurley
should not be mad cj anderson's getting
carries he already got his money does he
want to get a second contract and be
fresh let's see jay anderson take some
of those carries and the wear and tear
away from him the other thing i'll say
just to get excellent it's easier said
than done chris i mean it's easy for us
to say it but gurley
dan said it he's a competitor he wants
the ball he's not going to want to back
off in the biggest game of the year i
get that and in the biggest moments he's
going to be in there and you know what
and maybe he might not like it exactly
in the moment he's going to like it when
he wins a super bowl because of it and
that will change his you know status as
a legend forever and the last thing i'll
say is this just about xe and oe
football you know me because i'm a
quarterback is you know the one thing
too in this matchup that we can't forget
the saints they've changed their defense
from the way they played the first time
around they are primarily a zone defense
you got to be careful about playing
man-to-man against the rams because you
see all the speed sweeps and the things
they they'll make you go sideline to
sideline and have your head spinning
around where if they're living in zone
coverage then you know mcvay can dial up
a lot of plays to three on two a zone
coverage and find easy completions for a
golf that way as well so that would be
just something i would say look out for
uh as we're watching the game on sunday
i might at least i have no problem with
the todd gurley thing it's not
basketball right the guy can't hold the
ball he's got he's got to run the plays
that mcveigh you know runs maybe it's a
problem next year maybe it's a problem
in the off season it's not gonna be a
problem on sunday
i i think that that the rams are doing
everything they can to make sure it's
not a problem which tells me at some
level they're concerned it could be a
problem if there is a 50 you're starting
driving yeah you're starting i'm good at
it yeah i'm trying to stay i'm trying to
stay what's the what's the cliche from
hockey not where the puck is where the
puck's gonna be when you're stepping
ahead of the curve or whatever
chris i i gotta give you i gotta get you
always find creative new ways to to
completely warp the english language
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports